ce n'est pas une décision politique mais
une décision scientifique
heureusement un discours qui a bien
changé en l'espace d'un mois et demi
pour soutenir et emmanuel macron
considère maintenant le vaccin russe
comme une arme d' influence faut être
très clair nous sommes face à une guerre
mondiale d'un nouveau genre
face notamment aux attaques aux
velléités de déstabilisation russe
chinoise d' influence par le vaccin
face à cela si nous voulons tenir nous
devons être souverain nous nous sommes
mis aujourd'hui en capacité de produire
pour ce faire nos retards nos
manquements au tout début je considère
que nous avons rattrapé les choses et
que nous sommes en train de répondre à
cette crise des mots qui sont bien loin
de la réalité concernant cette campagne
de vaccination qui piétinent en france
et pourtant d'un point de vue purement
scientifique puisque en aucun cas la
décision
les politiques des solutions existent
spoutnik vie répond parfaitement aux
exigences d'un vaccin efficace contre le
coc vide 19 la très sérieuse revue
médicale britannique elle zélande 7
affirme début février qu'il est efficace
à 91,6 % surpassant de loin le vaccin
astrazeneca efficace à 76% et donc dans
la même cour que les moderna et autres
paysages johan peck eux mêmes sur à plus
de 90% le développement du vaccin foot
nivet a été critiqué pour sa
précipitation
le fait qu'il ait brûler des étapes et
une absence de transparence mais les
résultats rapportés ici sont claires et
le principe scientifique de cette
vaccination est démontrée cela veut dire
qu'un vaccin supplémentaire peut
désormais rejoindre le combat pour
réduire l'incidence du côté de 19
compte tenu de l'urgence sanitaire et de
la lenteur de la campagne de vaccination
en europe des questions peuvent se poser
au vu de ces conclusions
une demande d'homologation est certes
actuellement examiné par l' agence
européenne des médicaments mais en
parallèle une véritable bataille
géopolitique se dessine
jean yves le drian n'hésite pas à
employer les grands mots et considère
que le vaccin spoutnik v est utilisé
comme un outil de propagande à la
manière dont ces gérer c'est plus un
moyen de propagande et de diplomatie
agressive quand moyen de solidarité
et des sanitaires on pourrait presque
employer le terme déstabilisation si
chère à emmanuel macron en ce moment
quoi qu'il en soit si on s'attache à
refaire la chronologie du vaccin
spoutnik v la france tient un triple
discours pour le moins troublant d'abord
sceptique puis intéressé finalement
accusateur les développeurs du spoutnik
v ont d'ailleurs répondu à cette attaque
invitant le président français a laissé
la question des vaccins hors de la
sphère politique tout en soulignant
l'importance de la coopération cher
emmanuel macron rendre les vaccins à
politique est notre meilleur espoir de
paix mondiale et non de guerre
nous vous sommes reconnaissants d'avoir
envoyé une équipe scientifique française
sous la direction de marie paule kieny
et notre partenariat avec la france nous
a beaucoup aidés et contribuer à notre
combat commun contre le coc vide
oui la france a bel et bien envoyé
délégation scientifique à moscou fin
novembre pour discuter de la production
du vaccin russe une information
pratiquement passée inaperçue et
pourtant ô combien importante
aujourd'hui puisque ce voyage a été
approuvé par emmanuel macron 8 mails et
les conclusions de ce déplacement faite
par la chef de la délégation parlé
d'elle-même
le vaccin spoutnik v vaut la peine
d'être considérées dans la course
internationale
sa technologie repose comme pour les
vaccin développé par astrazeneca pfizer
par exemple sur deux vecteurs viraux
les données détaillées que nous avons
consultés semble correspondre aux
chiffres avancés dans les communiqués de
presse qui était jusqu'à présent notre
seule source
des déclarations qui concordent avec
celles de la revue lancet
rappelons également que soutenir et à
d'ores et déjà été enregistrées dans
plus de 50 pays
la sphère géopolitique prend le dessus
sur l'aspect sanitaire et c'était là
souvenons nous tout le danger qu'il
fallait éviter